man bike riding was so hard bruh
well y'all were nervous about me yes
why you're a bigger guy
and then you're on bikes yeah but i do
backflips that is true
yeah i know but we didn't know a
skateboard to be fair
to be fair to be fair you was going like
five miles per hour
yeah i know because i know my limit i
know what i'm well you guys went from
zero to it's like yeah you know it'd be
like a five minute skateboard before and
then you drop me off at venice [ __ ]
park you know and i gotta go down the
ramp but everything's
zero to 100 like you guys didn't just
bike ride you went on like
yeah we were going pretty fast and i was
hey listen i i was like i'm not trying
to impress anybody
i respect my speed see there's me it's
me jay and stevie right there if you
scroll no not well
oh the scooter game scooter guy scooter
gang i was so mad i wasn't there man
scooter yeah scooter game with justin
if you scroll up chen it's up
y'all did the tougher yeah the course
tougher course
dude and uh we tried to pick that bike
up i tried to do it like how you take
pictures that they
tired that friends hit me in my head
almost got a concussion yeah that's it
that's a heavy you're a strong guy bro
then when we were on the ski line yeah
oh the ski oh my god oh you guys went
i'm so mad because we didn't know what
we haven't been on a ski lift before i'm
so mad at you i'm so glad i'm mad at you
because you you you for one you jay and
stevie
have all the experience right y'all did
this before me
okay okay okay that's fair me chappelle
are you looking for a video chat yeah
did you guys have it somewhere oh tell
me
oh wait wait wait wait phone's over
there um go to justin's page
yeah he has a picture oh yeah justin ate
it what is justin
uh justin uncut uncut yeah
right there okay so his picture uh go
down right
that's right there i tried to pick it up
like i'm ready let me just go ahead
[Applause]
first of all those were the two those
two ate it and y'all were worried about
it
i didn't eat it i didn't eat it like
that let's just eat it you didn't have
dirt on your clothes because i was
looking for adjustments
and when justin ate it it was so sad he
flew up in the air and then
i wish you guys get that video and then
i wanted to but malik just rides by and
goes
i'm gonna talk about it because no let
me can i set it up justin what he wanted
to be
you he wanted to be the captain of our
crew he was like every time we're like
oh come on let's ride
that come on let's ride i'm like what
the hell why are you doing the [ __ ]
voice
don't don't shift it just look at this
last pose we're gonna try to go all sexy
little do they know he ate it on a bite
why his eyebrows like that like why he
confused like why you taking a picture
of me right now
look at this the first the first count
goes you look constipated
why they do them like yo he says you get
a better version
yeah you were right though he was trying
to be uh yeah the leader of our past
so when he flew and here's the thing
when he do he caught that blue he caught
everything flew out his pocket his party
passed his id the twenty dollars i tried
to scoop up
he he did and and he listen i stopped
for him yeah alex just was like
you know i had to it was so funny
because he wanted to be he wanted to be
the leader
he wanted to be the leader of the game
he didn't even know he was bleeding yet
i just go hey man you got something on
your arm
because i didn't want to say you got a
bloody arm because he was like man i'm
good you're like i'm like you got
something on your arm but his arm was
like
and his leg and his leg and his leg yeah
damn
yeah we i'm not i'm not doing that again
i'm not doing that yeah i don't need it
yeah yeah i don't know
but when i get off stage at the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song